[Music]
boy meets girl boy likes girl boy fights
evil exes years after its release the
untold truth of scott pilgrim vs the
world further reinforces what a
one-of-a-kind movie it turned out to be
even with all the famous roles michael
cera has inhabited it's still difficult
to separate him from his performance as
scott pilgrim and scott pilgrim versus
the world sarah's distinctive film
persona was just such a perfect fit for
the character and his gift for timing
means that he's responsible for the best
line deliveries and the entire movie
given how snugly he fits into this role
it shouldn't be a surprise that director
edgar wright always envisioned the part
as being one that only sarah could
portray as wrights told cinema blend in
2010 michael was my first and only
choice for the role wright noted in the
same cinema blend interview that he and
co-writer michael bacall first got the
idea to cast sarah when they saw him in
the acclaimed sitcom arrested
development they only wished he was
older at the time but as fate would have
it it took five years to get scott
pilgrim made by the time casting rolled
around sarah was the perfect age hi i
was thinking about asking you out but
then i realized how stupid that would be
so do you want to go out sometime
wright also noted that another advantage
to casting sarah in the parts was the
ability to contrast the film's intense
action sequences with the look and
mannerisms of someone like sarah plus a
young actor was canadian further
cementing just how right he was for the
part
edgar wright movies often have tons of
memorable supporting performances with
the likes of baby driver or hot furs
being two character stories chock full
of unforgettable supporting figures
scott pilgrim vs the world meanwhile has
the most packed cast of any right
feature with many of the characters
developed far beyond just
one-dimensional stereotypes working with
so many performers at once could
intimidate some filmmakers but wright
embraced a chance to work with such a
stacked ensemble cast as he explained to
cinema blend one of wright's favorite
things about the film is the way you can
watch supporting players in every single
shot and see a different version of the
story unfolding as right put it that's
very true to the books in the books
there's this kind of peanut gallery feel
where there's things going on and
nothing going on in the background and
the ensemble is always doing something
in the books i tried to pull that off in
the film as well
scott pilgrim vs the world is a
departure from other edgar wright movies
in several key ways including that the
project had a significantly bigger
budget than prior rights works like
short of the dead however another key
departure from wright's other films was
that this british born filmmaker was
insistent that there were no british
performers in the cast you want to fight
me
for her was that not clear
is that not clear
of course european talent is so
widespread in the acting community that
someone from across the pond was bound
to sneak onto the catalyst for scott
pilgrim versus the world satya baba who
played matthew patel in the film was not
just born in london but grew up in the
same part of london as wright himself
baba's years working in america were
enough to help him keep wright unaware
of his history during the casting
process
one of the performances most critical to
making scott pilgrim vs the world work
as well as it does is ellen wong's turn
as knives chow what could have been a
passive performance the forgettable
other girl to the more prominent ramona
flowers becomes unforgettable in wong's
hands what's especially impressive is
that wong makes sure chow never lapses
into being a mucking caricature even
when she's having a breakdown over scott
pilgrim seeing another older woman wang
injects a relatable quality into child's
character that makes us fully understand
her perspective given just how perfectly
she inhabited this role it can be
shocking to hear that initially one was
convinced she had no chance of securing
the part as she told entertainment
weekly as an asian actress i was never
going out for a role like this this was
not the type of role that i would be
able to even look at thankfully for the
sake of the overall movie wang not only
auditioned for scott pilgrim versus the
world but also scored the part of knives
in the process ensuring this film would
have one of its most important
performances
scott pilgrim vs the world has garnered
varying degrees of responses to its
approach regarding female characters
however one objectively true fact about
the film is that there are several women
in the story beyond scott pilgrim's love
interest from owner flowers and knives
chow played by the likes of brie larson
and aubry plaza among others these
characters and their comedic moments are
some of edgar wright's favorite parts of
this production as he told collider the
thing i'm really pleased about with this
film as opposed to some of the other
comedies out there and even stuff i've
done before is that it has a lot of
funny women in it given how the
characters played by performers like
plaza and larson became some of the most
beloved scene stealers in scott pilgrim
vs the world it's a good thing wright
made time to shine the spotlight on
multiple women in the film
while the widely acclaimed project scott
pilgrim vs the world has like any movie
not been without some criticism most
notably the film was being critiqued for
its casting which largely employed white
actors among those who have registered
grievances with this is brian lee
o'malley who pens the film source
graphic novels an author of french
canadian and korean heritage o'malley
has been open about his issues with the
eventual casting of the scott pilgrim
versus the world movie in a post on his
blog radio meru honestly when i saw the
scott pilgrim movie it was kind of
appalling to see just how white it was
to not even really see myself
represented on the screen he went on to
note that the casting on this film was a
key influence in his decision to add
more diversity to his subsequent works
including books like seconds these
comments reflect the complicated legacy
of even movies as well received as scott
pilgrim versus the world
american movies filmed in canada are a
dime a dozen thanks to the country's
generous tax incentives however these
productions usually use canadian
backdrops to double as other places
including famous american cities scott
pilgrim versus a well departed from this
norm by taking a cue from its source
material and setting scott's story in
specific locations all across toronto
canada to make sure he approached these
backdrops properly edgar wright did his
homework and committed fully to
understanding just where he'd be
shooting scott pilgrim versus the world
the globe and mail noted that scott
pilgrim vs the world was one of the
biggest films to be set in toronto up to
that point this feat was accompanied by
wright spending countless hours
observing the terrain of toronto and
making sure scott pilgrim would utilize
landmarks in the area brian lee
o'malley's graphic novels are extremely
specific in terms of where in toronto
they take place and wright made a
commitment to recreate that with the
film committing to this backdrop is
emblematic of the specific details that
make scott pilgrim versus the world such
a uniquely entertaining experience
the assorted action sequences and scott
pilgrim vs the world are a masterful
blend of visual and auditory elements
that required a lot of effort to execute
but one particular action scene turned
out to be the most challenging part of
scott pilgrim versus the world to film
this was none other than the climatic
showdown between scott pilgrim and
gideon graves as wright recalled in an
interview with entertainment weekly and
then there was this final set piece on a
pyramid suddenly we slowed down to doing
10 shots in a day which is very slow for
me i sat there on top of this pyramid
looking down at these enormous platforms
being maneuvered around and i thought
whose idea was this and it was mine
while the scene itself proved to be
exhilarating to watch unfold in a movie
theater it's apparent that complicated
sets and choreography made it an
enormous undertaking to actually shoot
thankfully for writing company all of
that effort ended up paying off
handsomely since his climactic battle
closed out scott pilgrim versus the
world on an exciting high note
from the very start scott pilgrim vs the
world makes it apparent you're going to
watch something special when a
performance from the band's sex bob-arm
triggers a visually aggressive opening
credit sequence the names of key casts
and crew members are displayed against
frantic animation and a wave of colors
that clue the viewer in on the kind of
visually unpredictable and audacious
movie they're about to absorb in
breaking this sequence down for the art
of the title sequence edgar wright
revealed several fascinating facets of
this segment including that his very
existence came at the suggestion of
quentin tarantino after the pulp fiction
director saw an early screening of the
film the artists in charge of crafting
these opening credits also had to come
up with their own unique visuals they
couldn't draw from imagery in either the
film itself or the scott pilgrim graphic
novels it took an enormous amount of
efforts and craft to pull off such an
unusual approach to an opening credit
sequence but the result was something
that made scott pilgrim versus the world
a captivating experience right from the
start music plays a big part in scott
pilgrim versus the world how could it
not after all scott plays in a band
called sex bob and so many of the film's
big action sequences begin with bands
performing on stage but music's
influence in this film was not just
limited to in-universe performances the
world of musicals also had a significant
influence on how edgar wright composed
the various major action set pieces as
the director told collider we thought it
should play out like a musical in a way
in terms of the fights are not
dissimilar to the songs i always thought
there were a lot of martial arts films
that were like musicals so we wanted to
take that further you see the results on
screen as many of the film's fight
scenes play out like elaborate dance
numbers it was a style right would take
a step further years later with this
musically inspired car chase film baby
driver
in the aftermath of scott pilgrim versus
the world failing to take the box office
by storm the conversation inevitably
turned to what went wrong one recurring
answer as to how such an acclaimed film
failed to click with audiences was to
look at the film's marketing which many
deemed lackluster and a key culprit in
the box office performance of course
those who made the film have their own
thoughts as to what it was like to
advertise such an unorthodox title
speaking to entertainment weekly for the
film's 10th anniversary in 2020 wright
opened up about the disappointment
noting how tempting it was to blame
other people for the failure the
director has been asked numerous times
over the years what the key factor was
for the film's box office disappointment
but he's always been resistant to the
idea that just one thing was responsible
in the end wright just seemed glad that
the film found new life on home video as
he told ew after the film didn't open
well i realized the thing to do is to
take responsibility for it but also just
believe in the fact that it was a good
film and people would find it eventually
and people did indeed find it eventually
today scott pilgrim vs the world is
considered one of the great cult
classics of the 2010s
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you